Hallo, guten Abend. Ich bin Ünlast. Ich bin als Assistant auf dieser Station tätig und heute für Sie zuständig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen. Seht Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Ich würde gerne erst mal ein paar Fragen zur Ihrer Person stellen. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Hans-Peter Engelbrecht. Könntest du Sie bitte Ihre Macht- und Vornahmen wuschen zu werden?
Ja, Hans-Peter schreibt sich h a n s, ein Minus, Zeichen Peter P e t e r. Hans-Peter ist der Vorname.
Und Engelbrecht e n g e l, wie der Engel.
Ja.
W r e c h und t Engelbrecht.
Ja, Herr Engelbrecht, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 61.
Wann sind Sie je n a geborgen?
Am 5. Februar 1962.
Ja. Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
1 Meter 81 und 86 Kilo.
Okay. Herr Engelbrecht, was für Sie so uns, was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ja, ich habe jetzt so seit circa 3 Stunden sehr starke Luftnot. Ich kann mich gar nicht mehr flach hinlegen.
Das kann ich nicht. Da wird die Luftnot noch viel schlimmer. Die Luftnot war in den letzten Wochen auch vorhanden,
aber nicht so schlimm wie jetzt seit 3 Stunden.
Haben Sie Burus-Schmerzen?
Nein, keine Schmerzen.
Jetzt muss ich unser Besprechbausüren. Ich muss Ihre Witterparameter messen und an EKG schreiben.
Okay.
Ja, bitte liegen Sie auf dem Lege auch.
Ja, jetzt, ja.
Jetzt Ihre Witterparameter ist stabil. Können wir weiter machen?
Ja.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben starke Luftnot seit 3 Stunden.
Wann ist diese Schmerzen, erst mal, wie sind die Schmerzen aufgerät?
Sie haben gesagt, seit letzten 3 Wochen, oder?
Nein, also ich habe ja keine Schmerzen. Das ist starke Luftnot. Ich bekomme keine Luft.
Das ist jetzt ganz schlimm seit 3 Stunden, aber in den letzten Wochen habe ich auch schlecht Luft bekommen,
aber nicht so schlimm wie jetzt heute.
Ich konnte nicht mehr die Treppen richtig hoch steigen.
Ich wohne im zweiten Stockwerk und da muss ich dann immer mehrere Pausen jetzt machen,
um überhaupt meine Wohnung zu erreichen.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben keine Schmerzen.
Keine Schmerzen. Ich habe keine Schmerzen, aber die Luft ist schlecht. Ich bekomme keine Luft.
Ja, haben Sie Luftnot auch in der Ruhe?
Ja.
Ja, 3 Stunden ganz stark auch in der Ruhe. Ich muss ziemlich schnell atmen und kriege schlecht Luft.
Leiden Sie unter Herzrasen oder Perfektation?
Wie bitte?
Herzrasen, leiden Sie unter Herzrasen?
Also ich glaube, mein Puls geht jetzt ziemlich schnell.
In der letzten Zeit war auch, glaube ich, schneller der Puls.
Ja, schneller als normal.
Gibt es bestimmte Auflöser für diese Luftnot?
Ja, wenn ich mich bewege, wenn ich mich etwas körperlich anstrenge,
das schaffe ich nicht mehr.
Ich muss mich eigentlich in den Sessel setzen oder ins Bett und mit vielen Kissen im Bett.
So kann ich ganz gut, so kann ich Luft gehen.
Ich kann jetzt nicht mehr gehen hier oder die Treppe steigen. Das schaffe ich jetzt nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden früher?
Nein, aber in den letzten Wochen hatte ich eben auch schon Luftnot, aber nicht so schlimm.
War es deswegen bei anderen?
Jetzt nicht, in den letzten Wochen nicht.
Aber sonst werde ich vom Arzt kontrolliert,
weil er sagt, ich habe mein Herz funktioniert nicht mehr richtig.
Ich habe auch eine schlecht fließende Herzklappe.
Und mein Arzt überprüft das immer, einmal im Jahr.
Und er sagte mir, wenn es jetzt schlimmer wird, dann soll ich sofort kommen.
Aber heute ist es so schlimm, da bin ich lieber gleich ins Krankenhaus gegangen, in die Klinik.
Okay, ich habe verstanden.
Hat Ihr als Deswegen ein Medikament verschreiben?
Sieben, verschrieben ja. Ich nehme mehrere Medikamente.
Einmal wegen meinem hohen Blutdruck.
Seit zehn Jahren habe ich hohen Blutdruck und da nehme ich ein Medikament.
Und ein Medikament, das auch mein Herz wohl etwas unterstützen soll.
Und ein Medikament gegen hohes Cholesterin, nämlich.
Wie heißen Sie Medikament?
Ja, ich habe hier ein Zettel. Auf dem Zettel steht KW D. Loel 1,25.
Dann nehme ich morgens eine Tablette und abends.
Und dann steht hier noch Kandy Satan.
8 Medikament, 1 morgens, 1 abends.
Und für Cholesterin nehme ich Rosu Vastatin.
20 steht dahinter, 20 nehme ich 1 abends.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie Husten?
Ja, in den letzten Tagen habe ich vermehrt Husten gehabt.
Und heute muss ich auch ganz häufig Husten und auch Schleim aushusten.
Können Sie bitte die Schleim beschreiben?
Ja, der ist so weisslich, weisslich.
Sonst nicht.
Nein, weißlich.
Okay.
Raus, das Zigarette.
Ich habe früher mal geraucht, aber das ist schon 30 Jahre her.
Da habe ich geraucht, aber seit 30 Jahren rauche ich nicht mehr.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraucht?
Na, so 15 Jahre, aber nicht viel. 50 Retten vielleicht am Tag.
Das war nicht so viel.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie Ihren Blutdruck gemessen?
Den Blutdruck?
Ja.
Jetzt heute nicht.
Ich habe mal hin und wieder Messe, ich mal den Blutdruck.
Ich glaube, letzte Woche habe ich mal gemessen, da war er so 145 zu 90.
Aber in letzter Zeit war er nie sehr hoch.
Der Arzt war eigentlich bei den Arztkontrollen,
der Arzt war eigentlich immer zufrieden mit dem Blutdruck.
Okay.
Haben Sie Luftnode beim Ein- und Ausatmen, beide?
Ja.
Ja, beim Arm.
Ich muss jetzt auch einfach viel schneller atmen, so ruhig.
Atme sonst ruhiger, aber heute und jetzt seit diesen 3 Stunden
muss ich viel mehr atmen, viel schneller.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie geschwunden, eine Beine?
Ja, gerade in den letzten Wochen, da sind die Beine immer sehr dick.
Und zum Abend besonders dick.
Und morgens sind sie dann manchmal etwas dünner, aber immer geschwollen.
Und das ist in den letzten Wochen stärker geworden.
Viel stärker.
Ja.
Eine Beine oder beide Beine?
Beine Beine.
Haben Sie Luft in der Beine oder nur geschwollene Beine?
Nein, sonst sind die Beine dick,
aber sonst sind die Beine in Ordnung.
Ja.
Haben Sie in Beine Krypton, Topheizgefühl oder Lebewung?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine Reise gemacht?
Keine große Reise.
Ich war im letzten Sommer, war ich 3 Wochen in Österreich,
aber sonst habe ich keine großen Reisen gemacht.
Okay.
Sind die Luftnoten beim Liegen verschrägt?
Ja, habe ich dich verschrägt.
Ich kann mich gar nicht mehr hinlegen seit 3 Stunden.
Da bekomme ich keine Luft, deshalb muss ich sitzen.
Okay.
Und in den letzten Wochen habe ich immer,
musste ich auch immer nachts mit mindestens 2 Kissen liegen.
Mein Kopf musste etwas höher liegen, sonst konnte ich gar nicht schlafen.
Und ich musste auch nachts ganz häufig auf Toilette und Wasser lassen.
Wie oft gehen Sie auf die Toilette nachts?
Ja, in den letzten Wochen so 4 Mal.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, ich hatte auch in letzter Zeit kein Fieber.
Nein.
Haben Sie nach Schweiß oder Schweiß aufgedrückt?
Ja, das hatte ich schon in den letzten Wochen.
Als das mit der Luftnot schlimmer wurde, hatte ich häufig auch mal nachts,
dass ich stark geschwitzt habe.
Und habe ich dann auch nicht mehr so gut geschlafen,
weil ich war mehr unruhig.
Ich war aber immer tagsüber sehr müde und sehr schlapp.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Nein, das ist in Ordnung.
Okay.
Was haben Sie noch auf die Toilette gegeben?
Haben Sie noch andere Probleme?
Ich habe keine Probleme.
Ich war vor einem Jahr beim Urulogen zur Vorsorge und Versuchung.
Da war alles in Ordnung.
Prostatei ist in Ordnung.
Aber jetzt in den letzten Wochen nachts viel häufiger auf Toilette
und Wasser lassen.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen Schwinde?
Ja, hoffentlich.
Ich habe auch noch eine Frage.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Ist Ihnen Schwinde?
Ja, heute seit der Luftnot, jetzt ist mir ziemlich schwindelig.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder so genommen?
Ich habe zugenommen.
Ich habe in den letzten vier Wochen ungefähr 5 kg zugenommen.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Appetit ist normalerweise gut.
Ich vertrage vom Essen her auch alles.
Aber in den letzten Wochen auch, wo ich die Luftnot so hatte,
war der Appetit nicht mehr so gut.
Ich habe mich allerdings auch weniger bewegt,
weil ich ja so schnell Luftnot bekam.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen Allergie bekannt?
Allergie habe ich nicht.
Ich habe nicht mehr.
Haben Sie vorstandig geimpft?
Ich bin, glaube ich, vollständig geimpft.
Ja, ich habe häufiger Arbeitsunfälle gehabt in meinem Beruf.
Und da wurde ich häufiger versorgt.
Und da kriegte ich alle Impfungen.
Tätternuss-Impfung und Diff-Therie.
Und Covid-Impfung habe ich auch alle gehabt.
Und das ist dazu Frieden.
Ja, okay.
Als Vorerkrankung, leiden Sie,
Arterie, Riechibotöne, Hyperchoreostomy,
gibt es noch etwas?
Nein, aber wie gesagt, mein Arzt sagte eben,
dass ich auch ein klaches Herz habe.
Okay.
Wurde Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als Kind wurde ich mal operiert.
Da war ich so, glaube ich, zehn Jahre alt.
Da wurde ich an den Mandeln operiert.
Und da war ich so, glaube ich, 13 Jahre alt.
Da wurde ich am Blinddamm operiert.
Ja.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber das ist nicht regelmäßig.
Ich trinke mal, wenn wir Besuch haben,
Freunde, da trinke ich mal ein Glas Bier.
Aber nicht jeden Tag.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich?
Das ist eine Routifrageweibung.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Die Mutter lebt noch.
Die Mutter ist 84 Jahre alt.
Die hat auch hohen Blutdruck und allgemeinen Gelenkverschleiß.
Arthrose in den Gelenken.
Der Vater, der ist gestorben mit 78.
Und da hat man gesagt, er ist an Herz schwäche gestorben.
Okay.
Ja, mein Beide.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder.
Er ist ein paar Jahre älter als ich.
Der hat hohen Blutdruck.
Ja.
Okay.
Was machen Sie von Beirut?
Ich bin von Beruf Tischler.
Ja.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und wohne mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Okay.
Ja, zwei Kinder, die sind 32 Jahre alt und 34 Jahre alt.
Ja, die sind gesund.
Ja.
Okay.
Ich habe meine Fragen gesteckt.
Möchtest du etwas hierzufügen?
Ja, was kann das sein?
Dass es mir jetzt so schnell so schlecht geht und ich keine Luft mehr bekomme?
Ja, ja, ja, ich verstehe.
Aber jetzt kann ich nicht momentan in einer genannten
Beide.
Für die weitere Untersuchungen und Behandelte,
Müssten Sie bei uns bleiben?
Bitte nehmen Sie einen Platz im Weitensimmer.
Ich riefe Sie gleich an.
Ja, danke.
Okay, können wir so machen.
Gut.
So, dann brauchen Sie jetzt einige Minuten und vielleicht...
Hab ich meine Kollegen und Kollegen andere Fragen.
Ich habe keine Fragen.
Okay.
Ja, können wir anfangen.
Hallo Oberjahrs.
Guten Abend.
Ich habe eine neue Person hier passiert.
Hat Sie sich Kurse zahlt für mich?
Ja, habe ich.
Ich berichte über den Patienten Hans-Peter Engerbricht.
Er ist alt und 60 Jahre alt.
Er ist 5 Jahre alt, 1902 und 80 Jahre alt.
62 Jahre alt.
Ich habe 62 Jahre alt.
Er ist 60 Jahre alt.
Er ist 1 Meter alt und 80 cm.
Er ist 86 km schwer.
Er hat sich heute bei uns seit 3 Stunden bei der Stärke auf die Luft.
Ja, die Düse, die Düse, die Düse vorgestellt.
Er berichtet, dass die Schmerzen seit 3 Wochen
nicht bei Belastung aufgeregt sind.
Schmerzen oder Symptome?
Symptome, ja.
Und wurden die Symptome im Laufe seit Verschlechter.
Er hat jetzt die Symptome in Ruhe.
Er klagte über Herz-Rasen, Farbitation, Angstgefühl.
Er leide an Herz-Rasen und Düstne.
Er nutzt zwei Kisten zum Schlafen.
Er leide an Herzklappen-Krankenheit.
Es besteht an amnestisch ein Hinweis auf ein Herzklappen-Vizium.
Er ist unklarer Lokalisation.
Der Patient weiß nicht, welchen Herzklappen er betroffen ist.
Er ist ein Herzklappen-Vizium.
Er ist seit 10 Jahren ein Arteriehrer.
Er hat eine Hypertons-Systeme.
Er hat in der letzten Zeit 4 kg zugenommen.
In welchem Zeitraum? Wissen Sie das?
Das ist die 4 Woche.
Er berichtet der Patient über eine Gewichtszunahme von 4 kg.
Er klagte auf Nüktürü.
Er hat 4-mal eine Gewichtszunahme.
Er hat beide Bein-Ödemen.
Er klagte auf 4-malige Nükturü.
Er ist seit 1870 in Sufianz gestorben.
Er hat eine Arteriehrer-Hypertons-Systeme.
Er schubst eine Heiß-Insofianz.
Wahrscheinlich eine dekompensierte Erd-Infizienz.
Er schubst eine Erd-Infizienz.
Er spricht vieles für eine dekompensierte Myokart-Insofizienz.
Er ist 61 Jahre alt.